did you talk to Julia I did you grabbed
her oh my god can I just say that is the
most exciting I think I've ever seen her
it was to what she's ever won ever ever
I was like I feel like you've I had no
one before could you tell how ecstatic
she was she was just shaking like a leaf
it was really cool it's very touching
how did that make you feel you don't
have any collaborations but to see these
artists you usually walk away with an
award with it where you collaborate it
was so happy for her I was so grateful
that she wanted to do this song with me
it was a blaster in the video like
sometimes videos can be work that was so
fun getting to just play and sing and
hang out so for everybody I hope so
yeah yeah we wrote a couple of things in
the record so she I think she's on about
four songs on the album as a writer yeah
yeah I know you read the premiere with
Nicole have you seen the whole season of
life yeah whole seven now are you a good
secret keeper extremely good you are oh
yeah I'm not gonna get anything out of
you know never divulge I wouldn't take
the fun away that's what it is
give us a little hint of something like
cow for a wild ride really as bad as
Meryl amazing everybody is just said
that I think at their best in this
happen
yep see is that we're gonna call us
tonight is she all promoting she's in
New York right now
yeah she's shooting another project and
I'm heading up for tomorrow yeah what
you guys gonna do for Father's Day I'll
let you know I mean that's it's always
surprised - surprise yeah you got plants
the little girl I'm quite sure they'll
have something right some things in
store yeah you're Nicole always post the
cutest videos on social media of you
guys thinking together she's actually
got incredible voice yes I know you've
been asked this before but I just want
to know you leaning towards that way at
all gonna do it do it together with your
beautiful wife I think those organic
ones are the way we do it the only time
we're gonna get to see what's real it's
legit yes I know well congratulations on
the winner so deserving always gonna be
[Music]
[Applause]